Everyone agrees that the epics,
Emily's and paradise lost are different from the epic similes in,
in any other epic poem.
And everyone agrees,
I'm just going to be presenting to you a sense of critical consensus here.
Everyone agrees that the similes are in some way,
absolutely essential to an understanding of this remarkable poem.
And everyone agrees that what Milton is doing in the similes is educating the
reader.
The reader of this,
of this poem,
he's introducing the reader to emotive vision,
different from the vision typically permitted him from within the poems,
uh,
more or less straight forward linear narrative boundaries.
The similes enabled us to see something about the story that the rest of the
poem doesn't enable us to see everyone.
I think that's fair to say that everyone agrees on that
and that's not nothing.
Uh,
but that's pretty much for the agreement
where the,
the agreement ends.
Milton's similes are notoriously difficult as,
as you no doubt have already experienced the,
and the,
and the poem seems unusually self conscious about the role that it's similes
play.
So think of the,
um,
the article on Milton similes by Jeffrey Hartman.
Hartman describes Milton's tendency in paradise lost and he takes this term from
Coleridge,
the,
the tendency to stand ob extra to stand from outside,
uh,
Milton's looking in at his own work from it from a distance according to
Coleridge.
And then Hartman and Hartman associates.
This image of Milton standing of extra with the figures in so many of those
similes who seem also to be standing,
uh,
extra.
And I think Hartman is absolutely right to note that it's,
it's this aspect of Milton similes that sets them entirely apart from the
similes and any other epic poem.
Um,
this,
uh,
everyone should have a handout would,
does everyone have a handout?
Yes.
Okay.
Um,
so this is my,
this is my first point.
There's also,
there's always,
and I think this is nearly invariable,
uh,
there's,
there's an element in Milton similes that stands outside the framework of the
basic comparison.
And in book one alone,
there are four primary instances of this.
What we can think of is this a primary similarly dynamic.
Um,
and we can call these the observers,
similes,
and it,
you see that they're listed on the handout.
So first we have the pilot of some small night foundered skiff and the pilot
stands up extra from outside in the simile and assembly is they're extensively
to to compare Satan with the great CBS Leviathan.
And in the comparison of Satan Shield with the moon,
there's the figure of the Tuscan artist,
uh,
the Tuscan artists being Galileo and Galileo appears in the simile but actually
seems to be unnecessary for the general purposes of the comparison.
And then we have the family of the fallen leaves the which compares the fallen
angels to fall on leaves.
And in that,
similarly we have the image of the,
of the Israelites,
the Milton calls them,
the southerners of Goshen,
and they're standing outside the general parameters of the comparison.
And so in each of these cases,
the figure who stands up extra from,
from outside is an observer and an observer looking in and interpreting the
action,
the action before him and observer in a position presumably to make some kind of
moral judgment on the action taking place.
Okay.
First of all,
let's look at the simile that compares Satan Shield to the moon.
This is book one,
line two 83 a.
This should be in the Hughes page two 18.
Okay.
He's scarce.
Had ceased when the superior feme.
That's obviously Satan.
When the superior fiend was moving toward the shore,
his ponderous shield,
ethereal temper,
Massey large and round behind him cast that broad circumference hung on his
shoulders like the moon.
Who's orb?
Through optic glass.
The Tuscan artist views at evening from the top of feds,
la or val [inaudible] know to describe new lands,
rivers or mountains in her spotty globe.
Let's,
let's try to take this apart.
The official function as I see it,
the,
the official function of this,
Emily,
is to give us a sense of the size of Satan Shield and thereby to give us a sense
of the size of Satan himself.
Satan Shield is as big as the moon.
Uh,
and this is the most common form of civil,
similarly,
Wa epic or otherwise.
And it can be ski.
Matteis well,
I'll,
I'm going to write on the board.
Uh,
she'll equals no,
and you can ski.
Monetize it with a,
let's say a equals a
prime.
A prime.
I prime
you,
you get it.
Something slightly different from me.
Uh,
that
what kind of makes sense.
Um,
but there's more of course here then the moon to describe Satan Shield.
It's a much more elaborate.
Similarly than that,
the broad circumference hung on his shoulders like the moon,
who's orb through tests,
through optic glass,
the Tuscan artist views.
And all of a sudden a third element has been injected into the comparison.
It has nothing whatsoever to do with the question of simply the size of Satan
Shield.
And we realized that we have to redraw the Schema into which we fit this simile.
Um,
so it's not merely a equals a prime,
it's a equals a prime x and x here would be Galileo,
the Tuscan artist.
The X of course doesn't announce its purpose within the logical context of the
simile.
And one of the Labors of reading paradise lost is the readers obligation to
supply the analog for the ex.
And this poem is filled with,
with such x's.
So what is it?
What is it we ask in the action of the poem that this x could be analogous to?
It's a good question and I think it still stands unresolved.
And the general understanding of this poem,
what is this observer?
I'm extra represent Milton's.
See,
similes always seem overstuffed.
They're,
they're,
uh,
they're over determined.
They always mean or signify far more than they're supposed to.
If their job is simply to make a comparison.
And there's never been any agreement is so far as I can tell as to who it is
we're supposed to be imagining the outside observer to be.
Uh,
and,
and there,
and there are all sorts of conjectures.
The,
the,
this,
there's the reader,
there's God.
Ah,
there's Milton [inaudible].
There are a number of possibilities.
Now,
this particular similarly conjures for us an image of someone trying to get a
fix on Satan Shield.
And there's this suggestion here of an attempt to get a proper perspective on,
uh,
on this huge character,
Satan.
And,
and by extension,
we have our attempt as readers to arrive at an understanding of the first two
books in,
in general.
And it's easy to say.
I think it's easy to see why Milton Milton would have wanted to do this.
There's no question that it's Satan who in these first two books,
a completely overwhelms our,
our imagination.
He is without question the most compelling figure,
certainly in the first two books.
And I think arguably in the entire poem.
And this fact is a con continually troubling phenomenon,
uh,
both for Milton and of course for Milton's readers.
And it only stands to reason I think that Milton would want to inscribe within
this poem the problem posed by this extraordinarily compelling characterization
of Satan.
How are we supposed to see state?
How are we supposed to arrive at some kind of proper moral discernment of,
of Satan's being?
And these,
this is a type of question that these similes are continually raising.
But let,
let,
let's,
let's wait.
We,
we,
we have further to go with this simile.
So initially the ponderous shield is of an a theory you'll temper,
we were told it is,
it has been tempered in,
it's a celestial fire in ether and it,
and it was the ether of the ethereal heavens that had always been thought
throughout the renaissance and long before,
of course,
to be the most perfect substance imaginable.
Yeah.
The moon too was widely believed to be a perfect sphere of fiery ether.
I'm like the sun.
It was thought to be a perfect heavenly body.
And as you probably know,
it was Galileo though the Tuscan artist,
the Italian astronomer who disproved just that assumption in 16,
10 when he published this idea,
Prius nuncius this the starry messenger.
So with his optic glass,
uh,
his telescope,
Galileo was able to discern spots on the orb of the moon.
It turned out to be a spotty globe,
just like the earth.
The moon seem to contain all of the geological imperfections of,
uh,
of earth.
There were no,
suddenly one could see looking through the optic last one could see valleys.
It seemed to have rivers that were mountains and it can no longer be said that
the moon was perfect.
It was no longer a fiery,
heavenly body.
It was no longer after Galileo of an ethereal temper.
And it's in this light that the introduction I think,
of Galileo in the simile starts to make a little more sense.
If we had been thinking,
and some of us may well have been thinking and we were right to think
provisionally,
that Satan was a character that we could actually identify with if we had been
thinking that Satan was in any way a perfect character with some sort of
justifiable claim.
These thoughts are now being corrected by means by the mechanism of the simile
like the moon,
Satan may look beautiful,
but upon a closer scrutiny,
that beauty begins to yield certain metaphysical flaws.
Okay,
that's one way.
That's one way to read the simile.
A one way to make sense of this mention of a,
of the ex,
the,
the Galileo figure.
It's a moral,
that's a moral reading of Paradise lost that I've just given you.
And,
and it's,
uh,
but of course it's only a partial one.
It's not simply because we haven't gone further and a half.
It's not simply the Galileo represents the admiring observer of Satan who is
finally able to arrive at adjust sense of,
uh,
of his moral spots and imperfections.
It's,
it's more complicated than that.
Galileo himself is viewing the situation from a fallen and,
uh,
and an unperfect uncertain perspective.
Galileo was only using,
of course,
his telescope in the first place,
a but because the,
his human capacity for vision is insufficient to see the truths of,
of the heavens.
Uh,
the and fallen.
Adam certainly didn't need a telescope to discern a lot about the heavenly,
the heavenly bodies.
And for further complicating the picture,
Milton places this scene of observation with the extraordinary care at the
moment of evening.
And you'll be noticing as you read and reread the poem,
just how many crucial moments in paradise lost occur at evening or,
or twilight,
uh,
that,
that privileged moment between day and night in which objects in our field of
vision are,
they may be visible,
but they're nonetheless indistinct.
And,
and indeterminate.
There's up there,
they're blurred.
So Galileo here is struggling to get the proper visionary fix on the moon at a
point in the day when they're at where there are no absolutes.
There's we're,
we're in between absolute day,
absolute night light and dark.
And Milton pushes this,
this image even further into and distinctness with an instance of the,
his famous deployment of the conjunction or,
and it has been argued,
and I think this is a brilliant point,
that the most important word in paradise lost is,
or the conjunction,
and,
and we'll be talking about why.
That's why that's the case,
but you'll get a little sense of it here.
The Tuscan artist views from the top of Fezza lay or invalid Arno.
Well,
on some level we,
we,
we'd kind of like to know which,
which it is.
I'm either on the top of a mountain or in a valley.
The vel Darn,
oh,
the valley of the Arno River in Italy.
The,
the,
the place names may seem just as superfluous here,
something additional that has nothing whatsoever to do with the actual purpose
of the comparison.
But Milton's uncertainty or the narrators uncertainty as to as to whether
Galileo has stationed his telescope at the top of a mountain or deepen a valley
raises an important question about the status.
Literally the status of the observer here.
It's not just that Satan or the moon or whatever it is that we're looking at
seems in indeterminate until we get,
until we get a proper look at it.
It's so much more complicated than that.
We don't even know where it is we're supposed to be looking from.
And the choice between Federal Land Bell Darn No,
uh,
that Milton gives the reader is,
is,
is crucial here.
The,
the,
the fact of the proliferation of possible perspectives is,
is just as important.
And I would think it's actually even more important as any single,
seemingly a proper perspective.
Okay.
This is only the first mention of,
of,
of Galileo in the poem.
And,
and as you will see if you're careful,
I'm looking at your footnotes in the Hughes.
He appears to other times within the later similes in the poem,
always in a similarly.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
you'll,
you'll have on the handout the other,
the other mentions in paradise lost of Galileo.
It'd be a wonderful paper topic,
um,
and examination of all of the,
of the Galileo similes.
And so it,
you know,
I think it stands to reason to assume that this figure of Galileo is of some
importance to Milton and the workings of the poem.
Galileo was the only contemporary personage,
the only 17th century figure.
Even so much as mentioned in paradise,
lost the rest of contemporary history,
including all of the stormy events leading up to Milton's own beloved Puritan
Revolution,
um,
in which Milton himself of course had participated.
All of that has been,
at least at the literal level,
at the explicit level,
has been expunged from the poem Galileo important.
Milton had written an area politica then that he had actually met Galileo on his
journey when Milton was a young man in Galileo was a very old man through the
continent.
It's anyone.
Milton met him.
Galileo would have been old and blind,
not unimportant to the later Milton and Galileo was under house arrest.
I'm at his home in fee as he'd been in prison for his intellectual,
daring and affirming the Copernican view that the earth orbiting around the sun.
He had rebelled against the supreme authority of the,
uh,
of the Roman Catholic Church.
And in this respect,
he provides the poem with something like an earthly version of the arch rebel.
Satan,
of course,
Satan who,
who rebels against the supreme authority of the heavenly father.
Okay,
well that makes sense.
Kind of,
but,
but the,
the Milton had clearly admired the astronomer and,
and calling him here,
the Tuscan artist in some,
in some respects,
we can see him forging an identification between himself as a literary artist.
And,
and Galileo was a scientific artist,
the rebellious artists,
Milton and the rebellious astronomer,
Galileo,
or continually threatening to,
to,
to lapse into some sort of identity with Satan himself.
And,
and,
and suddenly the distinctions that the simile works so hard to establish are
beginning to erode.
Not just that,
but the moral certainties that may have seemed distinct when we contrasted the
ethereal haven't with the spotty and the imperfect nature of Satan and of the
moon up those two begin to seem fairly hazy.
[inaudible] sets out to establish the moral polarities between good and evil.
But it then works almost systematically to undo that,
that understanding the perspective is an evening perspective rather than a
perspective of total illumination that the similes are continually working to
unleash.
Um,
and they're really quite unruly in this respect.
The to unleash the moral and the theological confusion that's so much of the
rest of the poem seems really quite eager to pin down and to fix.
That was the Galileo.
Similarly,
let's look at the comparison of Satan spear to the,
that's how big Satan's shield was.
Well,
how big is Taten spear?
Uh,
Milton compares it to the mast of a ship and a,
this is a line to 92 in book one,
the bottom of page 218 in the Hughes.
And this is the simile that Stanley fish brilliantly describes as central to a
certain temporal procedure,
common in Milton's verse and fishes interested in the temporal process of
reading.
And,
and in,
in general,
we can [inaudible].
And it's this extraordinary insight that he gives us.
We can only read one word at a time.
We can only read one line at a time.
And,
and,
and fish argues that the simile has no choice but to unfold over time.
And so in the example about Milton Spear,
we read first that this is line two 92 isn't how Stanley fishes reading goes his
spear to equal which the tallest pine hewn on Norwegian hills to be the master
of some great amaryl or flagship.
Uh,
an Amarillo is a,
is a big,
uh,
worship.
Now we may assume having read only that much of the Simile,
that Satan spear is as tall as the mast of the ship,
not a small spear.
And so we adjust our minds to accommodate because presumably when we weren't
imagining Satan to be that big,
we adjust our minds to accommodate this sense of Satan's tremendous physical
magnitude.
Sure.
Surely Satan is bigger than,
than anything when we had been assuming.
But the simile continues.
And as soon as we read the next line,
so we're struck with the possibility and surely it's just a provisional
possibility,
but we're struck by the image that Satan's spirit is actually quite small.
He's spear,
we're butter wand.
He walked with to support uneasy steps.
If only for a moment,
Satan suddenly seems old and frail.
This is a,
this is an image of an old man with a cane and we have to adjust our
understanding of his sophistical size one more time.
And of course,
uh,
necessarily his moral magnitude would be adjusted as well in our,
in our interpretation.
Needless to say,
we're not done that.
The similarly isn't telling us that Satan Spears as small as a wand,
a because what we have is a syllogism here.
Satan's Satan's sphere is to the tallest pine.
What the tallest pine is too.
A little,
a little bit he wand.
And finally we realized that same sphere is of an unimaginable proportion.
Uh,
just as soon as we've crowded our imagination imagination already with the image
of the spear.
The size of a Norwegian pine,
which took a certain,
an imaginative leap on our parts.
We realize that Satan and his spear are a measurably larger even than that.
And the s the similarly pushes the size of the spear clean out of our rational
comprehension.
And it's this process that is according to Stanley fish,
that the point of this simile and the circuitous logical route that we had to
take in order to arrive at this new sense of Satan size has everything to do
with our status as temporarily bound temporally constrained readers.
That the and the,
the genius of fishes reading of Milton similes is to understand the particularly
timebound nature of,
of Milton's bursts.
So first we read that that Satan spear is big.
Then we read,
or at least we think we read that Satan Spear is small.
And then we realize over the course of this reading process that Satan spear is
unimaginable.
And we realized that our timebound mode of knowing is ultimately inadequate to
understand anything about the inscrutable truths of eternity.
This is according to fish.
We can't know anything certain about the eternal and the immortal world of,
of Paradise lost except through these faculties we have.
And these are,
those are uncertain,
imperfect,
fallen a human capacities of reading.
Milton wants to the reader to know that she's fallen.
We are all fallen at any problem that we have.
And understanding that Theology of Heaven and Hell is our problem is our problem
has fallen readers and,
and,
and fish imagines.
Milton is always on some level slapping the reader's wrist,
reminding the reader of his or her phone knows that there's a constant
pedagogical correction going on.
That was Stanley fish,
the other great critic of the miltonic.
Similarly for my money,
uh,
it takes,
a completely different tack and that's Jeffrey Hartman who makes an argument
that might even be thought to contradict fishes argument,
although actually Jeffrey Hartman wrote his piece first and Hartmans and vintage
of the simile isn't temporal.
The way fishes was.
It's spatial.
And for Hartman,
the miltonic similarly actually permits the readers.
Something like the perspective of eternity,
a divine perspective.
Of course,
this is exactly what Stanley fish had told us was impossible.
And the rhetorical strategy that Milton uses to give us this perspective of
eternity is what Jeffrey Hartman calls Milton's counter plot like fish.
Hartman is most interested in the similes of the first two books,
the assemblies that provide some kind of window under the world of Satan and he
focuses on the simile actually that follows the simile of Satan Shield that
we've been looking at and it follows the simile of the of the spear that fish it
analyzed.
This is the simile of the leaves,
so I'm going to ask you to look at line 300 of book.
One
page two 19 in the Hughes,
Satan has roused himself from off the burning marl and he stands in order to
call up his fallen minions to rouse them to act great acts of heroism.
He stood and cold his legions.
Angel forms who lay and tranced thick as a tunnel leaves that strew the Brooks
and Vellum Rosa where the Atari and shades high overarched and bower or
scattered sedge afloat.
When with fierce winds,
Orion armed had Vic's the Red Sea coast whose waves or through abuse,
Cyrus and his Memphian chivalry.
While with proof this thing doesn't end well with perfidious hatred.
They pursued the southerners of Goshen who be held from the safe shore.
They're floating carcasses and broken chariot wheels.
So thick PBIS strewn abject and lost lay.
These covering the flood under amazement of hideous change
for me that absolutely shocking fact of this simile is that its primary purpose
is near merely to describe the number of angels who are prostrate on the burning
lake of hell.
They lie and tranced thick as a ta.
How many angels were there?
They life,
they'll,
they lie,
they lie thick as a tunnel leaves.
That's true.
The Brooks and [inaudible] Rosa,
but Milton Milton will pursue this similarly with such a relentless drive.
It's exhausting that,
that by the end of that,
we've,
I think we've probably forgotten its role and merely in it'll illustrating the
quantity of,
of,
of Angel Forms.
Now the angels lay as thick as the sedge on the Red Sea coast.
Uh,
when Pharaoh,
a Milton uses the Latin abuse Cyrus for Pharaoh,
when Pharaoh with all his Egyptian army chased the Israelites across the Red Sea
after God.
And this is a,
this is the story told an exodus 14,
after God parted the Red Sea to allow the sojourners of,
of,
of Goshen the Israel lights to cross.
So Satan's that described initially here as the wind god,
Orion,
a classical figure who,
who vexed or tossed the web waves of the Red Sea just to Satan is rousing and
inspiring his fallen host of angels.
But Milton continues to complicate this,
Emily,
and he quickly complicates our identification of Orion with Satan,
which wasn't arrived at,
um,
that easily to begin with.
So Satan may be like the Wind Orion,
but Orion here is also seen as vexing and destroying the Egyptians who's
carcasses wash up on the shores of the,
of the Red Sea and the Israel lights having crossed the Red Sea safely look on
at this destruction from the safety of their shore.
Think about it.
Something's gone.
Something's gone awry in this simile.
The window.
Ryan had initially represented the heroic,
uh,
they're heroic general of his troops.
Satan and Harmon,
uh,
Jeffrey Hartman would describe this as the,
as the plot of the simile,
but this wind or Ryan begins immediately to destroy the evil abuse.
Cyrus the Egyptian Pharaoh,
a figure that biblical history had long associated with Satan had considered to
be an earthly version or a type of Satan.
And so you have a wind God who's identified with sate and destroying Pharaoh who
has also identified with Satan justice just as he attempts to destroy God's
faithful.
And it's this final movement of the simile.
According to this ingenious argument by Jeffrey Hartman that Hartman calls the
counter plot embedded within the explicit plot of the simile is a,
is a secret,
a kind of buried narrative.
And it's a hidden story that illustrates Satan.
Self-Destruction.
Say it illustrates safe,
safe Satan self,
even as the main narrative of the seminal similarly portrays Satan's heroism
and,
and the,
and the plot around the simile is glorifying the heroic Satan here
and Hartman and ingeniously locates throughout a number of Milton similes.
This same dynamic of a,
of a redemptive counter plot.
It's as if there's this subterranean figurative movement movement at work in the
similarly that's continually reminding us according to Hartman of the calm
efforts of divine providence on behalf of us,
of good Christian men and women,
um,
some ultimate divine control over the evil actions of Satan.
Now,
the genius of Hartman's argument about the counter plot was that,
was that when it,
when,
when Hartman floated this argument in the late fifties,
was that it enabled us to understand not us,
we weren't,
we weren't born then,
but it enabled readers and Milton to understand for the first time something
like that theological purpose behind a lot of the most fascinating and,
and extraordinary rhetorical effects of the poem.
And Hartman made sense of the seemingly chaotic and confused movement of the,
of the narrators imagination here.
And this counter plot continues to reinforce according to Hartman,
our faith and the two most important elements of,
of the poem's theology.
And that's man's free will Milton Milton's doctrine of free will on the one
hand.
And,
uh,
Milton's insistence on the importance of divine providence.
On,
on the other hand,
God's fore knowledge
through the dynamics of the counter plot,
the similes reassure us of what Hartman calls the grease full coexistence of
freewill and divine providence.
Let's move on.
Neither of these critics,
neither fish nor Hartman discusses one of the most celebrated aspects of this
last Semele that we've,
that we've looked at,
and I,
and I have a little hunch that there's a reason for their neglect.
This is the initial part of the simile that describes the leaves,
excuse me,
thick as a tem,
the leaves that Stroh the Brooks and Vallum Broza where the [inaudible] shades
high overarched empower the,
at least since the 18th century,
these lines have been singled out for their,
for their beauty and considering the Milton as describing the hideous demons
under Satan's control.
The,
the pastoral elegance of this little similarly really catches us off guard and
there's naturally a lot of pressure on Milton to make this part of the similarly
beautiful and striking because he's echoing not just one epic poet,
but essentially he's echoing just about every epic poet,
homer and Virgil and well after them,
Dante and innumerable others.
Have all applied the simile of the leaves or some version of it to describe the
number lessness of the dead.
This is on your handout and,
and the Elliot as you can.
As you can see,
the warrior glock us uses the simile of the leaves to dismiss the importance of
genealogy.
Why does it matter what family I'm from?
He asks diabetes very like leaves upon this earth are the generations of men.
There's a kind of organic continuity that,
uh,
that men partake of just as the natural world does.
Virgil alludes to just this passage in homer when he describes the entrance of a
whole crowd of,
of people into the under underworld as the falling of leaves in the early frost
of autumn.
This is where,
this is where Milton gets to the tunnel.
And finally Dante alludes to this image of,
of the Virgilian underworld in the inferno when he describes the descent of
humanity,
the evil seed of Adam into the Christian hell.
And so it's Dante who first supplies the notion of fallenness.
The theological notion of fallen us to this idea of the fact that the leaves
have fallen because of course,
Dante,
unlike homer and Virgil is,
is a,
is a Christian and has access to the,
to the,
the,
the Christian myth of the fall.
And so it would seem to be dawn taze use of the image that has a primary
influence here on,
on Milton.
But as we might expect,
there's a complication in the way that Milton uses this particular image.
Val Ambrose is a place in Italy that Milton had actually visited.
He had as a young man,
he visited and Rosa when he was introduced to Galileo in theatrical lighting,
val,
Val and Rosa Literally Means Shady Valley.
And,
and I think it recalls Galileo shady place.
Val Dar,
no another valley.
Um,
as,
as you know,
in classical literature,
the dead are referred to as,
as shades.
But here in Milton,
simile shades merely means shade trees.
It refers solely to,
to,
uh,
to trees.
And,
and Val Bros is the place where the attorney in shades high overarched and Bauer
as it.
And if these trees are still supplying shade and Bowering the entire Valley of
Alan Broza,
the leaves haven't all fallen.
Of course they're,
they're only in the process of fallen of falling.
And I think this is an important distinction because what you have here in the,
in the,
in the middle of this,
similarly in Milton's account of hell is an image of a Bauer.
This is a little,
this is a little paradise,
a paradise on the verge of being lost as the shades lose their tree as their
shades Lou there leaves the leaves,
you're about to fall,
but they haven't yet fallen.
And I think it's the imminence of their fallen us,
that Lens,
this image,
it's a,
it's,
it's incredibly powerful emotional intensity.
And also I think it's,
it's beauty that now the similarly concludes with a strong sense of the hideous
change under annual year will recognize this pattern again and again and
Knowlton the hideous changed undergone by the fallen angels.
But what we have here is an image of the beauty of that change.
The beauty of the fact that the leaves are falling.
Both Hartman and fish argued that the,
that the rhetorical strategies of Milton's similes work to reinforce the
theological categories of good and evil.
They argued that,
that the similes are supposed to reassure us that there is a divine good that
ultimately overwhelms the evil,
the evil represented by Satan.
But neither of these critics was,
was able to,
to discuss directly Milton's aestheticization of the fall,
uh,
in the lines on Val and Rosa.
And that's because it's here where the rigid polarities between light and dark
and good and evil,
all of these absolute opposites,
shins be begin to collapse.
Milton opens up a shady space for something approaching a kind of moral
relativism were,
were black and white.
Theological theological categories simply don't apply.
And of course this is only provisional,
but the space,
the shady space exists.
Nonetheless,
he returns us to the lowly perspective that Galileo had had when he set up his
telescope and that other valley,
Val,
Val Darko,
and it's this lowly vantage point that's beautiful in part because it's a fallen
perspective,
not in spite of the fact that it's a fallen perspective.
Now,
I,
I think now we can see why these lines about the autumnal leaves are so
difficult for us to incorporate into a moral reading or a theological reading of
the poem there invariably cited as among the most beautiful and exquisite lines
in paradise lost.
But on some level they've proven the bane of,
uh,
of scholars because they can't be squared with any of the poems,
theological message.
And,
and this is the remarkable thing about so many of Milton's similes there.
They're always bursting out of whatever critical or,
or theological constraints that we work so hard to impose on them.
So for Stanley fish meant is always reminding us of our fallenness as readers
and we're continually being encouraged to,
uh,
submit all of our uncertainties and all of our doubts to two to the power of
faith.
God is in control of the universe and if,
and if the poem seems not that Stanley Fish,
uh,
believes in God,
but nonetheless,
his Milton certainly does.
God is in control of the universe.
And if the poem seems momentarily to suggest otherwise,
that simply Milton's way of reminding us of the extent of our,
of our fallenness and Geoffrey Hartman's theory had a similar tendency to align
the poem with a kind of a religious orthodoxy that the assemblies are for him
instrument in the poems,
larger agenda to reinforce our faith in the coexistence of freewill and divine
providence.
Difficult,
huge concepts and Hartman's absolutely right to insist that no theological
concept is,
it's important to paradise lost as freewill on the one hand and divine
providence on the other.
We can say that,
but I wonder if it's possible even for these similes to convince us of the easy
coexistence of these two incredibly important theological categories,
freewill and divine foreknowledge.
Long before Milton had begun to tackle the problem Christians had for centuries,
for Millennia,
a puzzled over the logical inconsistency between these two concepts.
If God,
uh,
and,
and we all have our version of,
of trying to wrestle with this.
If God knows what you're going to do to tomorrow,
to what extent does it make sense to say that what you do tomorrow you do
freely.
And Milton,
like a lot of Orthodox Christians will insist when he's speaking theologically
that God's fore knowledge has no causal effect whatsoever on the future.
And so it doesn't actually impinge on our freewill.
And,
and this is the god,
the father will make a similar argument in book three.
The conclusion reached in book three is that God has for knowledge,
but he isn't that interested in actual predetermination,
um,
or some type of divine action that literally compels the behavior of,
of human creatures.
And so it's possible presumably to say that Adam and eve actually had no choice,
uh,
they,
they had no choice when they decided to eat the fruit.
And even though God knew that,
of course,
no,
even though I said exactly the wrong thing,
this is how confusing the wandering mazes is lost that the problem of freewill
and foreknowledge puts us in.
Um,
even though God knew exactly what Adam and eve would do,
that they would eat the fruit,
we still have to be able to say that they ate the fruit freely out of their own
freewill.
Now,
scholars are ingenious in their ability to skirt absolutely.
Uh,
the central conundrum of providence that this poem raises and which it raises so
insistently and it really refuses to let go of it.
Um,
but that doesn't mean that the problem just goes away and I can't help but feel
that the winning team within the context of the actual story of the fall,
the fall of Adam and eve,
that the idea of divine providence isn't actually all that comforting.
The very idea of divine providence when it's injected into the story of Adam and
Eve's perfectly disastrous choice to eat the apple seems to arouse in a lot of
us feelings of injustice.
We,
what would we call this now?
This is,
this is entrapment.
What,
why did God place this stupid fruit in the garden in the first place?
If he knew in advance that Adam and eve were going to eat the thing.
And the very idea of providence in this context can in fact assume a kind of
menacing force that seems to compel men and women,
uh,
to their evil actions,
regardless of their theoretical,
they're technical possession of this capacity that we call that we feel very
comfortable calling freewill.
So Hartman and fish had been forwarded to perfectly ingenious theories of Milton
similes,
and they've had a tremendous impact,
rightly on generations now,
of readers of Milton.
They've taught us how to appreciate what strangest and most remarkable about
paradise lost.
But I simply cannot agree with their suggestion that Milton similes work in any
meaningful way to strengthen our belief in the Christian idea of the coexistence
of freewill and God's fore knowledge.
I,
I'm not convinced that that the poems radical and most subversive and most
exquisite rhetorical effects,
these amazing similes,
presents us with anything like a simple and unambiguous religious message.
Paradise lost as a whole clearly wants us to believe that God has for knowledge.
And it also clearly wants us to believe that we have freewill,
but the similes seemed just as often to open up and to question the poems.
Doc trinal conclusions.
It's the similes were not to sew everything up,
but make it impossible for us to maintain anything like the official position on
the,
on a moral distinction between heavenly good and satanic evil and Milton's
interest in moments of blurriness and have a visual in distinctness suggest that
the distinction between good and evil is,
is actually never that clear.
Okay,
we have time for another simile.
The last simile of book one,
this is page 231 in the Hughes.
This is the simile of the belated peasant that Hartman describes.
Um,
Satan in the fallen angels are entering the magnificent structure of
pandemonium.
And at one instance,
one instance,
all of the angel shrink in order to fit into the building,
however big it is,
which is,
but it's obviously too small for the angels to fit their in their proper
dimensions.
Look at line seven 79 of book one.
They a narrow room throng numberless like that pig man race beyond the Indian
mount or fairy elves who's mountain rebels by a forest side or fountain.
Well,
which is it?
And this is another important,
or by a forest side or fountain,
some belated presidencies or dreams he sees while overhead,
the moon sits arbitrary dates and nearer to the earth.
Wheels are Pale course.
They on their mirth than dance intent with Jochin music charm his ear at once
with joy and fear his heart rebounds.
Now the purpose of this simile is two events,
the indistinct anise and the confusion produced by our vision of the fallen
angels.
We can only imagine the fallen angels with the kind of dim uncertainty just as
the belated peasant sees,
or perhaps the only dreams he sees,
the dance of fairy elves by a forest side.
Uh,
now,
so,
so many scholars of Milton are under some sort of pressure to wreck,
reconcile everything in Milton's universe to a single theological mesh message.
Uh,
but I think there's,
there's,
there's something in this simile that resists our alignment of all the things
that the peasants sees,
uh,
with,
with the satanic world of unmitigated evil,
of,
of the fallen angels.
There's a difference between Fareol's and hideous demons.
I submit and with the phrase sees or dreams,
he sees Milton's alluding to Virgil's Aeneid who descends to the underworld and
catches a glimpse of the shade of his dead lover,
Dido,
or he thinks he catches a glimpse of the shade of his dead lover.
Dido.
The Virgilian echo gives this passage in Milton and an unmistakable pathos and
an undeniable beauty.
And as with the passage on the falling of the leaves,
there's a kind of elegiac tone that works to undo or at least to challenge our
theological certainty.
And as we noticed that this,
all these similes have these observer figures.
And this one does too.
Um,
there's a,
there's a second figure here,
standing up extra,
and that's the moon hovering overhead.
While the while overhead,
the moon sits arbitrators and we're naturally invited to question,
what force is it that this moon represents?
Now you remember may remember what Jeffrey Hartman had argued that the moon
represents the power of divine providence.
And there's a lot of ways in which this reading makes sense.
And Arbitrary [inaudible] is a judge and she would seem to oversee the justice
in this world.
And the question of providential justice is of course a primary,
uh,
significance to Milton's poem.
But Hartman goes on to say that the moon,
which reminds us of a common perfect sense of providence also works to guarantee
the principle of freewill.
So this is my question to you.
How complete and perfect is the image of providence that hovers,
that hovers moonlight over the pages of paradise lost.
I think Milton is encouraging us in these similes to question really to wrestle
with the theological certainties that the rest of the poem labors to establish.
And the,
and the uncertain status of divine providence here think has made clear by it's
by it's figuration as a moon.
And so I'm going to conclude here by reminding you what you already know.
We have already seen a moon in book one.
The Moon was compared to Satan Shield and Milton was preparing us then for this,
this radically ambiguous status of this providential moon.
It was Galileo's job.
You'll remember with his telescoped to detect the otherwise in detectable spots
and imperfections in this seemingly but only seemingly perfect moon.
And I'm convinced that it's the reader's job to apply the same degree of
critical scrutiny,
a kind of Galilean critical scrutiny to the image of providence that will be
elaborated,
as you will see at extraordinary length in book three of paradise lost.
So for next time,
you'll read book three.
Um,
you will focus,
however,
on the opening and vocation,
please do read all of the other selections as well.
You will have sonnets.
Little bits of pros.
We'll be talking about Milton's blindness.